liliana un muy buen ambiente recordemos
que este festival se aplazó normalmente
el festival de cannes tiene lugar en
mayo pero este año a raíz de la pandemia
tiene lugar en julio y además de hacer
mucho calor aquí en la croisette hay un
ambiente muy especial ya que obviamente
no hay mucha gente especializada hay
muchos periodistas pero no los 40.000
que cada día vienen tradicionalmente al
festival porque hay muchas restricciones
todavía de viaje entre los países sin
embargo están los veraneantes y
recordemos que cannes es un destino muy
importante de vacaciones de los
franceses que también producto de la
pandemia están pasando más sus
vacaciones en francia que en el
extranjero restricciones para la prensa
básicamente hay que tener un pasaporte
europeo sanitario eso significa tener
las dos vacunas al día para poder entrar
a ver a las películas sino hay que
hacerse un test salida hay todo un
laboratorio a los pies del palacio
festivales que ustedes ven a mis
espaldas con esa alfombra roja y no
habrá el beso francés tradicional del
delegado del festival a los artistas
cuando terminan ese paso por la alfombra
roja esta noche comienza ya la
competencia oficial son 24 películas que
van
juzgadas por este jurado que tú decías
el presidio por spike lee esta noche
tenemos el estreno de annette del
francés leos carax un directora raro
protagonizada por marion cotillard y el
actor de moda en hollywood adam driver
el director tiene más de 60 años y es su
primer proyecto en inglés